[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT 1: I didn't
know any trans
or gender-nonconforming folks,
really -- not out folks--
in the late '90s, early 2000s.
SUBJECT 2: Even
after I came out,
I was definitely shutting
down a part of myself
so that I could just fit in
with my existing friends.
SUBJECT 3: For me,
it was a huge deal
to have finally articulated to
someone that I was something
other than straight.
JUDY JARVIS: Hi,
I'm Judy Jarvis.
I'm director of the Princeton
University LGBT Center,
and we have this incredible
project, the Princeton LGBTQIA
Oral History Project.
The goal of the project is to
capture, record the stories,
and archive the stories
of LGBTQ Princetonians
from all different class years.
RITA KEAZER: I think I was very
naive, thinking that Princeton
was always the way it is today.
I forgot there had to be
an evolution that came here
and there were
lots of people who
had to really make sacrifices.
JUDY JARVIS: The goal here is
to really center stories that
have not always been centered,
to say to alums that what
your experiences were,
whether positive,
negative, some mix of
both, whatever they were,
they really matter, and they're
really important to students
now and to future students.
Elders in the community,
LGBTQ alums of color, trans
and non-binary alums
are really important.
So those were our
four focuses, the idea
being that not only do we
want to center LGBTQ voices,
but we particularly
want to center those
that don't always get centered.
PALOMA AGUAS: It felt
like an extreme privilege
to be able to learn
what Princeton
was like from the
alumni we talked with.
Having not known much about
the history of this institution
for when they went
here, and then
getting to hear what
their perspective was
like about that time
was really enlightening.
JUDY JARVIS: The Every
Voice conference in 2013,
which was for LGBTQ
alumni to come back,
there were actually some oral
histories done as part of that.
We knew that there
was a lot to tell.
So I reached out to
the Princeton BTGALA,
the alumni group, to gender
and sexuality studies,
to the University
Archives to see,
could we partner together
and do a project.
We know there's interest,
but do we really
have everyone at the
table to make this happen?
And excitingly, all
of them were all in.
They were so excited
to be able to capture
the stories of LGBTQ alums.
So with that partnership and
the funding of the Princeton
Histories Fund, we were able
to set off on this project.
We formed an advisory
board and that board
really said, OK, how
do we find alums?
How do we reach out
to folks, especially
those who didn't have a positive
experience at Princeton,
who might not be really
clicked into what's going on?
So we're on the cusp
of figuring out what
phase two of this project is.
So we did one summer,
collected the 73 interviews.
So now myself, the advisory
board, and our partners
are in the process of seeing if
we can get the funds together
to do another round
of interviewing.
So we hope that will come to
pass, and if it comes to pass,
we will definitely be looking
for more alums to interview
and we'll also be
looking for more students
to be part of the project.
RITA KEAZER: It does make
you have hope for the future,
feel like, well,
we've come so far.
There is long way to go, but
I think we can get there.
It's in our sights.
[MUSIC PLAYING]